here to respond wisconsin senator ron
johnson so senator you know it's
probably some stringer trying to land an
exclusive of a juror for the today show
i get that but
they're putting people's lives in danger
by speeding and running reds but there's
also something else
they're intimidating the jury and
they're saying the media is there we're
watching you we know where you live
we're following you
and however you decide you can be a good
guy or a bad guy by the way we cover you
you agree with that
by and large you know i think what this
trial has just highlighted is the
vast divide
in this nation you know president biden
in his inauguration speech said his
primary goal was to unify and heal this
nation he has not accomplished that goal
i wish he would have
but again this trial is just bizarre in
so many ways uh you watch the coverage
for example on fox versus the coverage
in cnn and msnbc it's like two totally
different trials i mean how can people
take a look at the same reality and come
across come away with such different
versions of it but the you know the the
peep the crowds banging uh
you know
making all kinds of noise outside the
courthouse blow horns it's got to be
intimidating the jury i don't understand
why they didn't sequester this jury
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
this is not the way our justice system
ought to work judges shouldn't be
threatened jury shouldn't be threatened
there shouldn't be intimidation and you
know jesse the other fact the matter is
i know the mainstream media doesn't like
to hear this but we're not concerned i'm
sure governor evers didn't call up the
national guard uh in the event that uh
kyle is is found guilty
it's only if he's found innocent this is
the same reason when when they boarded
up
storefronts in major metropolitan areas
prior to the november 20 election it
wasn't in the event that uh joe biden
got elected so the the threats of
violence primarily not all the time but
primarily come from the left
and of course the mainstream media won't
admit that which just exacerbates the
problem it's a very good point and
because you represent that state tell me
about the people of kenosha we're
looking at a jury
they were picked from the town the
surrounding area and they're taking a
very long time in my opinion
to
give a verdict they've seen a lot of
evidence they've seen a ton of video
again they asked for more
footage they're asking for more
instructions one of the female jurors
asked if she could take home the
instructions with her again they should
have been sequestered i completely agree
but
how would you
describe the people in this community
and and the people in this jury
good folks
uh that'll take the responsibility very
seriously and render i hope a very fair
decision but it's it's you know could
you blame them if they feel intimidated
uh that they're gonna take an extra time
and and prob maybe factor that
intimidation those potential threats in
their decision i mean that's what
concerns me and you know and then what's
also
tragedy about this is it this trial
shouldn't even be occurring right now i
agree we should not have had multiple
nights of riots had governor evers
stepped up the plate
brought in the manpower that
president trump offered him had he and
his lieutenant governor mandela barnes
not incited
the rioters by you know governor evers
issued a statement saying you know when
he knew no information about the
shooting he said what we do know though
is this is not the first time a black
man has been shot or injured or
mercilessly killed at the hands of law
enforcement was basically what he said i
mean that's just inciting the right as
did lieutenant
governor mandela barnes so they've been
completely irresponsible we never should
have had the riots uh not not multiple
nights of them had they acted
responsibly back in 2020 all right
senator ron johnson thanks so much for
joining prime time hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else